vor allem die kinder in den flutgebieten
in rheinland pfalz in nordrhein
westfalen aber vor allem eben dieser
region ahrweiler die sind nach wie vor
so ganz besonders betroffen todesängste
verzweifelte eltern zerstört ist zu
hause das ist all das was die kinder
dort in den vergangenen monaten erlebt
haben was in den köpfen drin ist
inwieweit julian amtlich diese eindrücke
jetzt noch mal aufs neue geprägt was
bringst du uns für erlebnisse aus dieser
region mit ganz speziell jetzt mit blick
auf die kinder dort in ahrweiler ja wir
bei bild haben es uns zur aufgabe
gemacht eben diese flut regionen dieses
ground zero oder flut dieses a nicht zu
vergessen dort mit vielen reportern
präsent zu sein ständig präsent zu sein
und dazu gehört auch man sieht dass hier
das sich selber jetzt zum zweiten mal
dort war und mit betroffenen dort
besprochen gesprochen habe in einer
ehemaligen gastwirtschaft mit
wundervollen eigentümern die es uns da
so gemütlich wie möglich gemacht haben
die natürlich auch zerstört worden ist
durch die flut und was ich da erlebt
habe hat mich nun zum zweiten mal
erschüttert vor vier wochen waren wir da
und die menschen haben mir erzählt hier
funktioniert gar nichts wir sind von der
politik im stich gelassen worden und wir
haben gesagt wir werden aufmerksamkeit
darauf lenken und meine hoffnung waren
natürlich dass die politik dadurch
aufmerksam wird dass sich etwas ändert
dort im aartal aber tatsächlich haben
wir menschen gerade von den kindern dort
erschütternden zustände berichtet es
gibt keine es gibt keine bürgersteige
mehr die bürgersteige sind zu großen
teilen weggeschwemmt es gibt geröll und
schlamm pisten die sich dort in lang
ziehen und über diese geröll und
schlangen schlammpisten müssen kinder
nun ohne licht ohne strom ohne
straßenlaternen morgens im dunkeln es
wird dunkel inzwischen es ist dunkel
morgens wenn kinder zur schule müssen
müssen da durch dunkle zur schule gehen
vorbei an baggern vorbei an
kettenfahrzeugen vorbei an planierraupen
die der fall absolut untragbare zustände
niemand fühlt sich da fühlt sich dafür
zuständig vor ort mal einen schulbus zu
schicken da gibt es dann so abstruse
begründung wie der bus weiß gar nicht
woher wenden soll na klar dann lässt man
lieber ein kind von einem raupenfahrzeug
überfahren wenn der bus nicht wenden
kann und all das ist klar die zuständig
der höchsten politischen ebenen in
diesem land malu dreyer die
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland-pfalz
unserer bundeskanzlerin angela merkel
die haben alle versprochen nationale
kraftanstrengung von kraftanstrengungen
kann dort nur die rede sein was die
betroffenen angeht die zeigen
bemerkenswerte kraft durchhaltekraft die
solidarisieren sich die sind dafür ihre
kinder aus der politik sagt man dort
erwarten wir nichts mehr wer sich auf
politik verlässt ist verlassen
das ist das meinungsbild dort im aartal
eine beeindruckende krankenschwester
sagte es ist unmöglich geworden hier im
aartal noch kind zu sein es sind
zustände wie ich sie mir in deutschland
nicht hätte vorstellen können und jetzt
kommt die nächste katastrophe und sie
kommt mit ansage und deswegen möchte ich
sehr so klar sagen möchte direkt in die
kamera sagen an malu dreyer die
ministerpräsidenten von rheinland pfalz
und an unserer bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel kümmern sie sich denn der winter
wird kommen nach ahrweiler wir spüren es
jetzt schon hier auf den straßen der
frost kommt wenn der frost nach
ahrweiler kommt wenn der schnee nach
ahrweiler kommt und bis dahin sich
weiter niemand gekümmert hat und wir
sind nur wochen oder vielleicht tage
davon entfernt dann werden dort in
ahrweiler menschen erfrieren weil es
keine heizungen gibt weil alte menschen
desolat zurückgelassen in ihren
wohnungen sind sich nicht mehr heraus
trauen wenn unsere bundesregierung sie
frau dreyer und sie frau merkel sich
nicht jetzt heute anfangen so darum zu
kümmern wie es angemessen ist wie es der
anstand gebietet um das ahrtal um die
flutgebiete dann werden dort im winter
bei einer angekündigten katastrophe von
der wir alle wissen sie wird kommen
werden dort menschen erfrieren es werden
kinder überfahren werden morgens auf dem
schulweg weil es keine
transportmöglichkeiten für sie in die
schule gibt und das ist die
verantwortung der ministerpräsidentin
dort und der bundeskanzlerin die
zusammen aufgetreten sind ja die
zusammen hand in hand durch die
flutgebiete gegangen sind und gesagt
haben wir werden helfen wir machen das
wir lassen euch nicht allein nichts
anderes ist dort passiert allein allein
allein sind die menschen dort und vor
allem ihre kinder sind schreckliche
schilderungen wie uns erzielt wurde wie
die kinder wunderlich eigenbrötlerisch
werden sich zurückziehen nach anderthalb
jahren corona die sie nicht wirklich
raus durften jetzt vielleicht raus
dürften aber da draußen ist nichts mehr
die spielplätze sind wegradiert ihre
fußballplätze sind weggeschwemmt ihre
sportstätten sind weggeschwemmt nicht
existiert mehr und die menschen dort
schildern uns einhellig dass nichts
wirklich geschieht in dem ausmaß wie man
es in einem land wie deutschland
erwarten könnte um diesen desolaten
zustand so zu beheben dass menschen und
ihre kinder dort endlich wieder wurde
voll leben können drei monate nach
dieser katastrophe die bilder die wir
sehen die glühbirnen brennen das ist der
strom den wir mitgebracht haben mit
einem dieselaggregat dort funktioniert
weiterhin nichts und wenn es so
weitergeht sagen die menschen nach der
ersten katastrophe die unangekündigt
court kam und dann kündigt übrigens
falls kein alarmierungs und kein
alarmsystem gab wird die zweite
katastrophe kommen und die kommt
angekündigt und sie heißt winter und es
wird dort menschen geben die in ihren
wohnungen erfrieren es den menschen
zugehört julian bei unserem bild flut
stammtisch dass dir die sorgen die nöte
die ängste zu ihren zugehört und dass
sie sich hier auch mitgebracht und eine
einige wirklich krasse aussagen auch
mitgebracht die wollen uns jetzt anhören
zum beispiel von gereon haumann es
hotelier und präsident vom deutschen
hotel und gaststättenverband in
rheinland pfalz wenn sie mal rein
folgende erwartungen haben wir an die
politik erstens damit die unternehmer
aber auch die bürger mit gutem gewissen
hier investieren können brauchen wir den
weltbesten hochwasserschutz für die a
wir sind das land der ingenieure es muss
uns gelingen hier eine benchmark zu
setzen zweitens brauchen wir eine
verkürzung aller baugenehmigungen hier
ist die kreisverwaltung und die
nachgeordneten behörden zu unterstützen
mit zusätzlichem personal damit
baugenehmigungen rechtzeitig kurz und
knapp erfolgen können und drittens
brauchen wir eine unbürokratische
auszahlung von geldern auch unter
inkaufnahme dass manche fehlgeleitet
werden wir leben einem rechtsstaat
fehlgeleitete zuschüsse müssten
zurückgefordert werden aber die große
masse muss er schnell geld jetzt schnell
und unbürokratisch überwiesen bekommen
das sind botschaften der unternehmer
dort der hotelier dornheim an diese
botschaft muss direkt weiter gehen an
die politik hier in berlin an die
politik in mainz einmal drei diese
botschaft gibt es ja seit monaten
schnell und unbürokratisch wenn wir nach
drei monaten der seit drei monaten aber
es geschieht nicht ein beispiel was mir
die menschen dort gesagt genannt haben
dass ein jahr wirklich zwischen weinen
und lachen zurück lässt es gibt online
antragsformulare die man ausfüllen muss
dieser online antragsformulare um geld
zu bekommen um wieder aufbauen zu können
was versprochen worden ist wofür
milliarden steuergelder bereitgestellt
worden sind diese online formulare haben
pflichtfelder zum beispiel die
steueridentifikationsnummer oder die
personalausweisnummer problem die
meisten menschen dort haben ihre
steueridentifikationsnummer
personalausweis was man aus während
weist sie haben ihre steuer- und ihren
personalausweis nummer nicht mehr wenn
sie sie nicht eingeben können können sie
gar nicht weiter klicken und geld
beantragen wenn sie sie in einigen
glücklichen fällen noch haben und weiter
klicken können dann können sie dort
auswählen wo ist der schaden entstanden
zum beispiel haus und dann muss man
angeben wo im haus im dachgeschoss
vermutlich nicht bei einer flut im
zweiten stock vermutlich er auch nicht
bei einer flut soll ich euch sagen was
fehlt in diesem kleinen job down menü
das uba der ort wo jede wo diese flut
eingeschlagen ist natürlich unten im
haus das kann man dort leider nicht
angeben deswegen kann man für das
zerstörte sutra leider keine hilfen dort
beantragen es ist so wahnsinn wir haben
ihnen versprochen wir lassen sie nicht
allein wir hören ihnen weiter zu
deswegen auch unser bild flut stammtisch
deswegen unser flut büro wo sie sich mit
ihren sorgen und nöten auch direkt
hinwenden können und julian reichelt es
hier bei uns hat weitere stimmen der
flutopfer mitgebracht dennis bayers ist
einer von ihnen und es ist wirklich
schlimm was er durchmachen muss verein
ich habe meine
firma quasi verloren das büro ist weg
das gebäude muss zum teil abgerissen
werden meine wohnung ist komplett
überflutet worden
und ja ich stehe halt gerade vor dem
nichts
ja die fahrzeuge sind weg wir sind
stehen ein bisschen vor dem nichts
wissen im moment nicht wie es weitergeht
mich regt ziemlich auf dass die
versicherung so lahm r schießt das gegen
gutachter schickt immer noch wohl gar
keine fahrzeuge da sind die sind noch
gar nicht gefunden das gibt behörden
nicht arbeiten dass die städte die
gemeinden einfach nicht aus den puschen
kommen und personal bereitstellen um
anträge zu bearbeiten und auch die
fahrzeuge diese weggeschafft haben nicht
wieder auffindbar sind
dass julian das klingt wie ein o-ton von
vor drei monaten er ist aber ganz frisch
der kontron der kommt von vor wenigen
stunden quasi dennis baars hat mir
persönlich erzählt er hat einen klar
nachvollziehbaren flut schaden erlitten
hatte nämlich eher lkw und dieser lkw
sind weg nach der flut weg da sie weg
sind kann er aber nicht belegen was der
schaden daran ist und deswegen krieg der
achtung kein geld für diese lkw das ist
nur eins von beispielen anderer
beeindruckender alter älterer herr
dessen
geist nicht gebrochen ist erzählt mir
sein haus ist zerstört worden und das
hat ein gutachter ist es ein gutachter
gekommen und hat festgestellt das haus
ist zerstört worden daraufhin ist er zu
der zuständigen behörde gegangen um er
sah um schadensersatz um hilfen zu
beantragen und dort sagte man ihm sie
brauchen doch noch ein gutachten dann
hat er gesagt aber ich habe doch der war
doch jemand hat ein gutachten erstellt
haben gesagt 'für das ist nicht fertig
geworden da müssen sie jetzt wohl selber
nochmal einen zu erstellen lassen der
mann ist unverrichteter dinge und ohne
einen antrag stellen zu können wieder
weggegangen die menschen dort erzählt
mir auch es fehlen vor ort nur dort wo
wir waren immer 260
verwaltungsangestellte die diese masse
an anträgen überhaupt bewältigen und
bearbeiten können es ist in den letzten
drei monaten niemand offenbar darauf
gekommen verwaltungsangestellte von
denen wir nun wahrlich viele haben in
deutschland vielleicht pensionierte bei
menschen die sich mit anträgen auskennen
dorthin zu schicken und dafür zu sorgen
dass die anträge der menschen überhaupt
in jenen genommen und bearbeitet werden
können all das ist nicht geschehen und
ich habe als ich dort war daran denken
müssen wie die wiedervereinigung
der mauerfall vor 31 jahren in
deutschland beglückt hat und was alles
möglich war jeder mensch aus dem osten
100 mark begrüßungsgeld an der nächsten
bank das war vor 31 jahren dass wir das
organisiert haben dass das war eine
nationale kraftanstrengung das was dort
passiert ist keine nationale
kraftanstrengung sondern eine große
kraftanstrengung der bewundernswerten
betroffene lernen und eine absolute
schande im kanzleramt und in denen in
der landesregierung dort vor ort
[Musik]